this is a production of Cornell
University
alright we're here on Long Island a
couple things I wanted to show you in
this Chardonnay vineyard so first of all
no herbicide they've been managing
without sprung underneath the vines
which is usually the common practice
they've used a lomo grass so it doesn't
get very tall and what they've done has
gone through and used to read whacker
when they've moved it to keep it really
low I so far the sim should be working
really well there's lots of questions
about what's appropriate to grow under
the trellises but the nice thing is and
no herbicides through here looking at
the fruiting zone clearly there's
recently been a leaf removal where I'm
at east side of the vines and so they'll
often do more leaf removal on the east
side compared to the west side because
this is where the early morning scent is
and the west side will be in the Sun
later an atom is showing you the west
side now and you can see there's more
coverage on the west side of the vines
compared to the east side of the vines
the other thing I want you to note when
you're looking through this fruiting
zone is look at the diameter of those
canes these are beautiful perfect
diameter a really nice amount of fruit
not over cropped not under cropped this
is a really nice amount of fruit to hold
back some of the vegetative growth of
these vines and that's why we're not
singing bull would through here we're
seeing a wood that's going to be
appropriate in terms of diameter when it
comes to pruning and looking up at the
top of the canopies I they've recently
been through here with the header and
cut off the tops we can see the new
growth just started peddling as a common
practice that we have to do in
vertically shoot position to canopies
because the vikans will grow over and
down if we don't do it overall in the
Chardonnay Chardonnay vineyard things
are looking great
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu